I guess it's join us here today we want
to work on sculpting the inner thighs
and also apps in bed using a pillow no
fancy equipment you don't need a gym you
don't need a big space all you need is
your bed or a mat and a pillow so we
really want to work on squeezing the
inner thighs and engaging the entire
core there are five exercises the
workout time is 20 seconds each with 10
seconds rest in between so we want to
complete two tests in five minutes okay
it's only five minutes give it your best
and your inner thighs and app will be on
fire right guys get in bed lie in bed
all right the first workout is going to
be a pillow pass so grab your pillow you
can fold it in to help if you want to
okay so I want you to start just right
above your head and past the pillow in
between your makes and release and
crunch up grab a pillow and just pass
okay so when you pass the pillow really
squeeze you like to fight together and
feel your inner face working good
the really crunch all the way up past
the pillow and grab the pillow crunch up
and just relax so the second word up is
great to be a crunch so just place the
pillow right under your lower back and I
just want you to lie down and crunch up
alright so by placing the pillow under
your lower back what you're doing is
that you're also elevating and
increasing the range of motion and mix
it more effective for the cultures to
really target your upper up keep going
guys one more
as now grab your pillow throw it again
and just squeeze in between your knees
okay really squeeze your inner thighs
and we want to perform reverse crunches
so tap down up lift your butt up and up
good so really squeeze and engage your
inner thighs don't let the pillow loose
squeeze and engage good keep going feel
more
last one and release now same thing
squeeze the pillows in between your feet
and straighten your legs we want to go
in a huge circle clockwise okay so
really go engage your lower abs and
gauge your inner thighs and draw a big
circle nice crease and engage your core
do not drop the pillow not now and draw
a big circle good final workout squeeze
the pillow in between your knees again
tilt Casteel back and we want to do hip
reach okay
the lift the butt off squeeze release up
and squeeze the inner thighs squeeze the
butt relief up pull and squeeze release
up hold and squeeze and release and
after this we want to go for the second
set okay so the first workout is a
pillow pot right grab the pillow above
your head leg straight and let go now
top squeeze and crunch up grab the
pillow half crunch up grab it like
really squeeze those inner thighs
crunch using apps your lower and the
upper apps release and pop good now get
up place the pillow directly under your
lower back okay you can't stack two plus
if you want to and now let's go for a
nice good solid crunch up cute little
bit out nice oh I can really feel my
upper abs and gauge more good last one
and just release the pillow fold it into
half squeeze it between your knees and
now we want to go for reverse crunches
okay squeeze so
by the inner thighs tap and crunch up up
lick your butt off and up to lift your
bike off the bed slightly engage your
inner thighs for your core working two
more last one good now let's place the
pillow in between your feet and go the
opposite direction ready again opposite
squeeze and gauge big circle remember to
breathe in and out good really feel that
you're engaging and working on your
inner thighs as well do more keep going
good and finally tip bridge okay
nice solid squeeze squeeze and gauge do
not let the muscle loose at all let's go
up squeeze squeeze every single muscle
okay
every single one your inner thighs your
thighs your butt muscles squeeze your
abs we're at the top good keep going
two more squeeze last few more seconds
and just press it out huh and just
stretch it out you should really feel
your inner thighs and your abs working
the key is to really squeeze your thighs
together in order to engage your inner
thighs so what I really like about this
workout is that you can do it anywhere
and anytime you can do it the first
thing in the morning or before you go to
bed and you can even do it in your hotel
room which is what I'm doing right now
and you can also take this workout to
the gym and replace the pillow with a
small bowl to make it more challenging
use a slightly weighted ball and you
will really feel that you're working
harder on your inner thighs and also
your apps so be sure to like this video
share this video with your friends get
them to do this workout and subscribe to
my youtube channel for more fun workout
videos recipes and also fitness tips
check out
more workout video links right at the
end of
[Music]
[Music]